glass-half-empty is a terrible way to
live life like looking at everything and
being pessimistic is the worst thing
that can happen to you everybody under
says I'm a piece of [ __ ] and in my own
mind I'm like we'll see it's very
strange how I live life when you
actually believe in the value you're
providing selling promoting giving for
free when you believe it all clicks the
motivation watch a top ten with the lead
nation
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack on chewing today's lessons
from a man who went from being born in
the Soviet Union and growing up selling
baseball cards and flowers to wanting to
buy the New York Jets and become the
greatest entrepreneur of his generation
he's Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take
on his top ten roses success volume 8
also if you want to know what Gary Vee
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a free
30 second a 5-minute video in the
morning to help you build your
confidence check out the link in the
description below on a bigger macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be optimistic number one you have to
find a way to genuinely appreciate
yourself for your strengths and your
shortcomings
people are just stunningly attractive
some people there's about thirty two
guys tonight here in Dallas that are
about to get drafted that were
remarkably athletic you know I wasn't
either one of those two and like that's
okay but I know how to sell stuff and
I'm a good guy and like you know to me
what I would say to people is the
judgment you're placing on yourself was
created through either a combination of
DNA or the way that you were brought up
and you need to spend time with
optimistic positive people that aren't
judging you to break out of that
framework glass half-full is a terrible
way you know like see the glass half
empty is a terrible way to live like
like looking at everything and being
pessimistic is the worst thing that can
happen to you and you should do
everything in your power whether that is
going and seeing somebody whether that
is changing your friends whether that is
abruptly getting up and moving to Peru
for the rest of your life whatever you
have to do to get out of a place where
you go negative is something you have to
figure out whether you have to listen
I'm not a doctor but whether you have to
get medicated whether you I feel like
like what my biggest thing is who do you
spend time with and who do you consume
if you're spending all your time with
pessimistic friends
you're in deep if you're listening to
the news all the time you're in deep
rule number two make no excuses and this
is my biggest point everybody this is
why I don't allow complaining or be
yelling for people that want to with me
because no matter what I'm gonna point
to somebody who had the same exact sit
Oh what you had a crackhead father and
your and your mom you sexually abused
you and you got stabbed cool let me show
you this kid who actually had that exact
same thing and he won and what we're
talking about right now is the reason I
win I'm not worried about the little
details this is all macro blueprint
strategy mental strategy no matter what
we say right now P I'm gonna show you
somebody who grew up with the same exact
situation have different outcomes and so
for me
everybody's dwelling on their
shortcoming the bottom line is no matter
where you start
everybody has paths to winning and
losing for me the best move is to take
control your no matter how tough you are
right now get rid of loser friends and
family introduce yourself to positivity
or winners and watch how it plays out
rule number three be better than
everyone in today's world where
everybody can win that means that
everybody can win which means you have
to be better than ever before to break
through right
everybody's got a hot take on the great
push to beat everybody's got a hot take
on the Golden State Warriors and LeBron
everybody's got a hot take on Ben
Simmons and Kendall dating everybody's
got a hot take on Roseanne Barr in that
world where you're gonna have to be
better at content and distribution and
so yes it is hard and I always tell
people they're like man it's so hard I'm
like at least you have a chance in 1982
if you weren't picked by somebody and
one of the 17 people that got to have an
opinion you weren't hurt rule number
four be driven by gratitude I think for
me the the game is driven by gratitude
gratitude is my fuel I think most people
burn out because they're looking for
money they're looking for short-term
highs you know when when the game itself
and the process and gratitude is the mix
of your gasoline you'll run forever when
it's about getting a watch or buying a
new home or getting a new pair of Yeezys
you're finished and so I see a lot of
people looking for quick highs I want to
get that girl I want to get that guy I
want to get that plane I want to get
that you know car that is just not
sustainable when you're like I cannot
believe I'm alive thank you so much and
oh my god I can't wait to wake up and
fight and grind and try to win it I love
the game you're unstoppable
I just never run out of energy because
those two things never run out the games
forever and gratitudes forever rule
number five only care about your opinion
I'm trying to figure out how to get this
for everybody cuz it is the I think it's
the ultimate I lived in my own head
nobody had say when I tell you nobody
had say still to this day nobody has say
nobody has say very early on there was
only one voice in my game my own it's so
scary to me how singular my own voice is
it doesn't mean that I don't listen to
feedback it doesn't mean that I'm
delusional and I think I can get away
with batch and it's all okay
I could say something right now in this
podcast everybody under says I'm a piece
of sh and in my own mind I'm like we'll
see it's very strange how I live life
it's it's way more extreme than you
think it's way more extreme than I think
I'm just like kind of like going through
it right now I'm like what the this is
crazy like it just means that I'll be
incapable of valuing anybody else's
opinion including my mom's my wife's and
my children's opinion about me over my
own if you realized how much of the
actions you do is to show your mom or
your dad or your sibling or your spouse
or somebody show somebody else that you
made it or you did it it is remarkably
scary how many people are dictated by
somebody else's opinion rule number six
my personal favorite believe in what
you're doing I'm secretly worried that
I'm going to get to a place where I'm
not gonna care anything about business
and it's the love of my life but I can
like feel it already in like you know 55
to 75 is gonna be some run when you
actually believe in the value you're
providing selling promoting giving for
free when you believe
it all clicks the reason people don't do
is because they don't believe they odd
either are insecure and structured that
way or they deep down know they're doing
it for the money
how many people like did things for me
with expectation I've done and most of
the times I'll say no because I don't
even want to do that
but once all I say yes mainly to stick
it to them and teach them a life lesson
which is don't come at me and be like I
want to do this awesome thing for you
and then kind of hover around and always
have this weird relationship with me
where they expect something like we did
something here like if you told me up
front that the reason you bought 10,000
books and did this thing was because
what you really wanted was my face on
your website co-signing your [ __ ]
business well then you should have told
me because then we get ahead a
transaction rule number seven eliminate
dwelling a lot of your advice is geared
like college grad yeah but I'm old I'm
40 what would you be like what was your
voice advice be for someone who's 40 but
starting out where most of your audience
is very high when they're twenty or
thirty what's interesting
no joke I don't know if you saw that I
literally posted a video today to 47
year olds so to me everybody's going
through different things you know I
to your point last 8 12 to 18 months I
found myself producing a lot more
content to youth than I have in the past
which was usually two more 40 year old
business people look I think the biggest
thing with 40 to 50 is that it's now
you've lived life and you're still young
as and you're like now what right you
have like an entire second life to live
and it's a very interesting time in
people's lives where they have to be
really retrospective of like how
self-aware are they but honestly I think
forties young man I really really do and
so I would say a lot of the advice I
give to 20 year olds Maps pretty well to
40 year olds which is you know take some
risks you've tasted some stuff you know
happiness is the ROI and so you know
figure out what makes you happy is that
the
suit of money or is it actual money new
materials make you happy if materials
make you happy is that really just
insecurity and you need to have you know
a BMW to make yourself feel good like
what's making you tick but I would say
the biggest thing that I would tell any
40 year old is you've got 50 years to
live please get the finished or I've
stopped like eliminate dwelling cuz
you're just starting I really believe
that by the way this is not some
motivational rah-rah sh I just think
it's true I just think you've got 40
dull years to live that's 20 more than
you've lived there's just so much
opportunity rule number eight start
small I'm Johanna and I just launched a
platform for connecting companies with
social media influencers okay like a
tinder self-direct and I thought I had
kind of a unicorn and now when kind of
exploring the world I say okay there's a
lot out there but we're kind of late
here in this part of the world yep so
here I captured the markets really well
in a short time that's awesome but I
wonder how my dreams about
internationalization and getting global
and making it scalable making it bigger
what advice would you give to me for
that ooh a couple things first of all
how big is it in the market that you're
winning in it the biggest thing that you
know that like unless you're doing 7 10
12 million dollars in the Nordics you
should not be thinking about Eastern
Western Europe us too many people like
every word out of your mouth is that I
was just talking like scalable what like
we're just all caught up in building
billion-dollar it's so stupid like how
big is your company how much are you
doing over a million now we have a
pretty revenue I mean it just launched
it until you make money you shouldn't be
worried about global no so local markets
go that way they were media did seventy
five million dollars in revenue
profitably before I thought about even
going to London okay everybody's caught
that listen I'm telling you all of you
you're caught up in [ __ ] propaganda
you're not thinking about it smartly you
make no money and you're sitting here
worried about winning globally and you
haven't even started winning locally you
understand yeah
thinking like it's partnership the way
to go somebody better oh no the way to
go is to not think about it at all okay
do you understand yeah yeah
rule number nine get leverage what I
tell people to do is get the leverage
you know let them go to your Instagram
and see ten thousand people there in an
active community let them hear that
you're selling out every time you have a
new thing then they're gonna come to you
the thing I do extremely well all the
fancy people every fancy person you've
ever seen me with any anyone
Tony the ROC anyone anyone I've never
reach out to them let everything come to
you all of them and rule number ten the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is care about your audience I've
hit that kind of quiet crescendo moment
where like it just I'm so in tune with
like putting out content putting it out
there letting you guys consume it
reading your feedback in this viral loop
and just feels like I'm in that zone and
every day I wish for you guys out there
in the world to find that same zone and
so look for that thing find that thing
and for me this community is that thing
and I want to thank you from the bottom
of my heart thank you so much have the
best best rest we can have the best
summer flip start things produce content
but most of all listen you know the
audacity that everybody wants likes and
comments and subscribers but doesn't
want to then do for them what they want
to return the selfishness of like give
me vanity metrics and social and content
and digital yet the key is if you
listened and cared about those
individuals as much as what you wanted
from them and likes the subscribers
everything would be different
please do not take things for granted
and most of all do not take your
community for granted because it's the
foundation of your opportunity in this
digital world
now I've got a really special bonus
garyvee rule on how to love the client
that I think you're really gonna joy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your business and your
life answer these three questions
yourself in the notebook at home talk
about them with a friend or leave them
in the comments below here we go
question number one whose opinion are
you worried about that is holding you
back
question number two what small way can
you start immediately on your goal and
question number three what excuse do you
need to get rid of right now thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
I am like every other human when
something ends I also have a moment
where I don't have the energy but for me
the game of trying to be a great
entrepreneur and the game of being
grateful as the operating system of your
soul is a forever game you know what it
is
I like Milo's as much as I like my highs
[Laughter]
like I like losing I think it's part of
the game
I think it's appropriate I think it's I
like being humbled because then I get
hot I get pumped like like I love when I
lose it's like I love them if there's
like a new game that I find where looks
like pickleball are like smashed but
like or darts in college I remember I
was like oh really like I love the
feeling of getting my ass kicked at
first because I love the climb and I
don't I also am very into my own head so
I think a lot of people struggle when
they lose because they're worried about
what everybody else takes and I'm like I
don't give whatever because the things
like they suck too altruistic world
domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video